do we know what's going on with this tv
show what's happening with vanderpump
rules
they haven't canceled it so there's hope
still
well you've launched a podcast you're
going to love me
which i can only think
is a message to the haters out there
that title you're gonna love me
yeah no that's i mean that isn't that is
a lot of it yeah so
taking from my experience of being on
the show
and and getting put into boxes and
labeled
those certain things that i didn't feel
like was truly who i am at the core i
mean yeah i do have moments i can be
mean i can be a [ __ ] but
i'm not a [ __ ] there's a lot more to me
and i was just thinking about
how many other people who are in the
public eye deal with the same
thing and just if we wouldn't know them
a little more
deeper on a more personal level just
diving a little deeper and
opening up your mind and trying to put
your opinions and judgments aside
so it's it's fun i i i really love
talking to people and getting to know
them and um
challenging my opinions for sure what
would you say the biggest misconception
is about you
oh my gosh the biggest i think people
don't understand that i do have a really
big heart i
deeply care about my friends and so if
i'm
being a little harsh on them it's
because it's coming from a good place
you cannot accept that you [ __ ] up i
apologize for untrue statements
look bad oh my god if people just
understood kind of like my thought
process
i think that i think it would make sense
to them and they wouldn't see it as such
a negative so i think people think i'm
just
this really like hardened [ __ ]
basically do you want to start off easy
or
do you want to just get right into the
knit gritty well
the knitting gritty well like everyone
asked me how i feel
how do you feel honey thank you i
appreciate that i feel overall okay i'm
happy
i have a lovely wife and beautiful dogs
i had a lot of fun listening to
the breaking bubba podcast you and tom's
what a really fun
conversation you guys said on the
podcast that
baby bubbas are a thought you're
tracking things
yeah half of the pregnancy pact
is in effect lala is pregnant stassi is
pregnant
is that pressure on you and brittany to
get pregnant
no i think i i i cannot put pressure on
myself like that you know
it's just you gotta just let it happen
when it happens and even though
we're active about it um you still can't
control it but
i'm so happy for lala and stasi that i
just
i don't don't even compare it to me
being like well i want that it's just
it'll happen for me when it does but in
the meantime i love hanging out with
them because it's just like they're like
should we get dessert i'm like
yes i love hanging out with pregnant
people because they love
all the food it is amazing so much fun
um well let's talk about your friends
because your friends are on a tv show
with you do we know what's going on with
this tv show what's happening with
vanderpump rules
i have no idea i mean obviously it's you
know with
covet and everything there's been so
many safety
and health you know restrictions and
obviously we want to heed that that's
the most important you know it's not
just us in the room we also have a crew
of people too so
and with the restaurant shut down you
know
it's hard to have a sexy unique
show without a sexy unique restaurant
but yeah i don't know i mean i swear
like i'm just
every day like being like maybe today
we'll get the phone call but
no i'm hopeful they haven't they haven't
canceled it
so there's hope still at least there's
not like anything definitive in that
regard but i think it's just kind of
waiting for a window of opportunity
maybe i don't
know it's so frustrating i i think it's
frustrating for you guys and frustrating
for the fans because i think everyone
just wants to know
what is going to happen because no
matter what if the show comes back it's
going to look
different two big exits stassi and
kristen
are not going to be a part of the show
and i feel like we've had people leave
the group before and the season comes
back and it's like
it's not really a big deal because they
weren't integral to the group
or to the story this is different do you
at all have
any idea of how you guys would approach
having that video
and they try to picture what it's going
to look like now and it's a little like
it's
it's weird yeah it's definitely going to
feel different and look different
but it's not like they're not a part of
my life
you know so it's it's gonna be weird to
have this
part of my life that was very much on
the show not on the show anymore
but i think it's just i guess we'll
cross that bridge when we get that i
try not to think about it too much
because i don't again i don't even
know if it was a show but um
obviously yeah it'll be it'll feel weird
it'll have to be addressed in some way
and i think people understand why
it happened but we have been so invested
in your guys's life for
so many years and i feel like so many
things are happening
right now between stasi's pregnancy and
then the three of you the witches are
back in action you're friends again and
we're not gonna get to see that journey
yeah yeah it's crazy but i mean i
i i didn't know what it would take for
chris tonight to come back together as
friends but i guess it was
this um yeah it's a bummer
how are stassi and kristen doing it was
it was hard for a while but i think
they're just trying to focus
on you know the future and what that
looks like for them and
trying to stay positive and not look
back but look forward and
um do this yeah do the work that we're
all doing and
and and yeah i don't know i mean there's
not much to say i can't really speak for
them and i don't feel it's right too but
um you can imagine um how it was for
them but they're you know they're
taking it in stride and definitely you
know
holding themselves accountable i
do you think it would have been an
interesting journey to see them have to
come back from that on the show to
explore these things on tv like i think
there was there could have been an
opportunity to do that and
maybe that's you know there's the whole
call for like jax needs to be held
accountable too but maybe that's the
journey we'll watch him go on
is facing some of those past yeah
yeah i know why do you laugh um yeah
just because jax is there's only one jax
taylor
you know this is his own breed
an interesting part of the conversation
that i've seen is if you go
back and watch the finale in hindsight
of last season
you guys all leave tom tom and it almost
looks like
a serious finale it plays weird knowing
what happened after
i totally agree because i remember
watching that being like this feels so
final what the hell i cried i was just
like this is really
heavy like normally i feel like our our
seasons always end on like a happy note
like it all works out
lisa's you know being like we're friends
we gotta stick by each other and it's
all this like
full circle kind of thing and this time
it was just like
but i know it was good i i thought it
was really great finale but yeah it felt
very vinyl
i was like um right what does this mean
should the show come back the black
lives matter movement is going to have
to be something that's talked about
because it's part of the reason why the
show's different um
and you and ariana were actually the two
people last season who were
upset by the police prank what kind of
conversations would you like to see
happen
on the show around that subject i think
it's
you know we do have a responsibility to
shine a light into all the blind spots
that we've had
really own and recognize that and
unlearn those things that have
been you know inherently built into us
i think it's about being aware of our
privilege and
and trying our best to understand so i
think it's just about
how we're doing that in our own lives
have you been having those kind of
conversations already within the friend
group
oh yeah oh yeah totally i mean
it's it's i feel like it's impossible
not to it's really necessary
so but it's all been good everyone is i
think
um putting themselves through the paces
and doing the work
even if it's not you know being shown
out there
all right i have some burning questions
about your time on vanderpump rules you
go back to that pilot episode
that katie maloney says her dream is to
work
at or run a record label i love working
at sir
but ultimately i want to have my own
record label
and not have to sling food and drinks
to pay my rent was that a real dream
yeah before the show started i was
actually i had interned
at warner brother records in the a r
department
i was trying to find a job in like a
publishing or licensing
house somewhere in la before the show
happened and then
i wasn't having any luck and then the
show got presented so i was like well i
guess i'll go
try this out since the other stuff
hasn't happened but no it was it was a
real
dream of mine but i've had lots of those
maybe one day though you never know it's
never too late casting is getting you
into that space you're now in the audio
space so that's not you're not that far
off
yeah it's true that is true pucker and
power
what happened where what's going on oh
yeah
um god pogba power was such like a
little like
love child of mine for so many years and
i had so much fun
creating that and i loved you know
sharing my little beauty hacks and tips
and secrets
but it got to a point where it was kind
of like vlogs were
like falling off a little bit apps were
becoming more popular and so it was just
kind of like i didn't know
i got blogger burnout and i didn't know
what to do and how to
you know brand it really so i had to
just kind of step away from it for a
while and it still stopped away from it
it's still around it's still up um but
i don't know maybe i think i think about
often especially being in quarantine i'm
like well
it's like that's all the time taking it
back to the podcast
do you have a favorite episode so far i
know you're only a handful in but you
have a favorite so far
oh um sarah nicole landry
we talked about you know uh loving
yourself and loving your body
and body confidence and body neutrality
and
all of that and it was such a great
conversation and she's just such
an inspiration like her content that she
puts out on instagram it's just
it's just like feel good content she's
just like i don't give a [ __ ] i've tried
to start following more
um people like her so that way the
content i am seeing
is good for me you know you've shared
your health journey recently and i feel
like your body is something people felt
like they had ownership over and that
they could talk about
for as long as you've been on vanderpump
rules um
is sharing where you're at now part of
that same journey of
following accounts that are promoting
kind of
a healthier mindset when it comes to
healthy living yeah i think that's
absolutely part of it
um just because my main focus through
all this is just to be
healthy not to be a certain size or a
weight
or look a certain way but to just be
healthy
it's a relationship that you have to
work on
every day so if it's if it's having a
healthy mindset
and following people's journey and who
are
of the same like mind um then that's
even better because it's just more
encouragement and motivation to keep on
going
you think being on tv has helped or hurt
your relationship with your body
um both having my body always be a top
of the conversation
everywhere online and on the show
was really hard and so that's when it
was hard but
having gone through that has helped me
now
so it's both i don't i don't regret it
that's so sure that's good all right
dream guest who's on the bucket list for
the show i mean i'd love to have on
rihanna obviously um
i'd love to have on like chrissy teigen
just because she's so hilarious i just
would like
feel like i laughed the whole time but i
also want to like she showed she shared
so much but i feel like i still have a
lot of questions
too about her growing up and
um the life before we knew her as
chrissy
um and i would love to have on someone
with monica lewinsky
that'd be a really just walks through
in the middle of you he's talking about
monica hi tom
come over here for a second come here
good to see you
oh he just got off the peloton so oh
miss you you look good hopefully we can
hang soon
i miss human beings
what did i tell you i'm not enough for
him
i'm sweaty i'm gonna go all right
let's go back you want monica lewinsky
yeah a monica lewinsky would be a lot of
fun too because she's somebody who
i mean yeah the very public scandal that
happened
but who was she in all of it you know
she was just getting labeled as like
a thought basically and
i'm sure she has a side of it too and i
just i would
want to just hear her talk and she's now
turned into you know uh like she does a
lot of public speaking
and talking about um like online
bullying and so
i think she's really turned it into
something
i would like to hear yeah i would like
to hear that conversation i love that
your show is
dialed in enough that it's like i think
anybody can go on it but it really
opens the door to people who
we have a preconceived notion of yeah
but even people who aren't necessarily
the bad guys or the villains or the
[ __ ] even the ones that you think are
like
so sweet and perfect they're not all
sweet and perfect
i don't want to let them make them look
bad but i think it's about people's
you know having new thoughts and
opinions on somebody
so it just it comes down to just
humanizing people right like we can all
meet at the same level of being human
100 that's it well congratulations
i'm glad you also have something to keep
yourself occupied in quarantine
something to do something to look
forward to a show everywhere
that and legos so yeah what's the before
i let you go tell me about it what's the
lego thing
do you have a room just filled with
legos
look at this well i got okay this is
like um
it's supposed to be a replica of the
chanel store
in amsterdam and then
over here this is like the major
we've got oh i got this statue of
liberty
this is a parisian cafe uh we got the
friends set
got a little diner got this thing
you've got your own lego land going on
we have
this over here were you in are you into
lagos before
quarantine or is this a passion that was
picked up because you're stuck at home
i had never done a lego set before um
but it's just it's like therapy for me
cathartic whatever i call it
legos as therapy okay yeah